i just been crushing sopranos it's a
really good show i just feel you're
gonna slowly start
adopting things you're gonna come in one
day like all leather
coat
no it's gonna be that is that style
where he wears like the polo
short sleeve polo with some weird
pattern on it yeah it is a great he
drips
which is
very clear because every girl wants to
[ __ ] him i don't get how much that guy
[ __ ] there it is yeah right there there
he is our boy rest in peace what a
wonderful character truly lovable
but a villain at the same time yeah you
know that's how people like it
like tom
like tom oh
oh are we gonna do
we're gonna talk about
where do i fit in
yeah we're gonna we're getting into
success speaking of getting your [ __ ]
dick sucked yeah dude suck sessions
spoiler alert
spoiler alert
please fast forward
at least five minutes
uh i know it's gonna be 20 minutes yeah
yeah this is we're talking about c uh
season three episode nine
the season finale of success
god damn
one of the best episodes of television
i've ever watched
how is it glued to the screen like this
the whole time
like a child yeah really yeah
i mean it was really cool seeing how all
the foreshadowing hit
you know someone brought up in
uh season one that kendall said
uh
dad is so [ __ ] jealous of what he's
given to his kids that he would take it
all from them and he did that
yep um and then
did you did you rewatch that clip of tom
helping logan take a piss
uh no i didn't oh man the dialogue in
that is very like so
when when
logan was going mad from the uti and all
the kids were arguing with each other
tom was the one to help him to the
bathroom to take a piss
and so he's
holding up logan
and uh
he's like do you do he's like do you
need some help do you want me to help
you to stand uh
do you want me to hold the scepter or do
you got it like talking about his dick
and he's like no i got it then he turns
to him and he puts his hand on him he
says thanks son
and then and then you know there's like
all these sort of like little moments
leading up and so when he when tom
burned them all
it kind of made sense so did did shiv
know at the very end was that her look
yeah i think so she she realized that
she thought of
logan leaving and like putting his arm
on tom's shoulder right
well i mean and i think she was like
holy [ __ ] and shiv said all this [ __ ] to
tom like
you know
[ __ ] you i don't love you oh god that
moment was horrible yeah
so why wouldn't he burn her yeah oh yeah
absolutely [ __ ] her
[ __ ] shiv yeah
[ __ ] them all
and then you know there's all the other
great pieces of symbolism too bad you
know
i i i feel what was nice in the whole
thing was that uh
kendall i felt kind of got vindicated
he he's like i try to take this dude out
yeah you guys clowned me the whole time
you called me an idiot maybe i didn't do
it right yeah look yeah
he just [ __ ] you both yeah
and then roman finally you know yeah
roman being on his knees at the end and
kendall like holding his shoulders being
like now you know how i feel yeah that
was pretty wild yeah
get [ __ ] god what a good episode roll
reversal seriously yeah it was um
it was crazy everyone's acting in that
episode oh my god that last scene
of logan oh my god logan [ __ ] mock
shiv yeah but you need the majority yeah
yeah dude i died
i was like holy [ __ ] i was like oh
and i mean your majority
shut up shut up
everything was
it's perfect it was perfect i don't want
to re-watch it
sam i was thinking that yesterday yeah
it was so good i just want to see it
again
but you need the majority yeah dude
get [ __ ]
i also love uh
lampson is that his name the ceo of gojo
what's his name oh um
love that guy for some reason
i don't know why like
weird actor but like weirdly charismatic
alex alexander skarsgard he's not a
weird actor no i don't know i mean he's
definitely what's happening in roles he
was in pretty little liars he got his uh
fake dick smashed okay yeah okay yeah
that's right the [ __ ] out of his dick
yeah yeah oh yeah
wait that was him that was him the
husband yeah oh
i meant weird character i mean like they
give him kind of like a
i don't know
his vibe is off yeah
yeah um you could just say that he's
dutch
weird like european vibe
like a weird kind of european dude just
say you don't like dutch people okay
just just tell them that's not what it
is
cody hates dutch people confirmed
when logan told roman to leave yep i was
i was thinking
just like that yeah you're just gonna
[ __ ] out all the kids just like that yep
because logan did the math he's like oh
pretty much this does work for me
so here's my question is like do the
kids
they're worried about maintaining
control of the family company
and obviously the company will kind of
cease to exist once it's part of gojo or
whatever yeah
they're not [ __ ] in terms of wealth
right
like they're not going to be as powerful
because they don't
they're not in control of like a major
corporation
but like they're still gonna inherit
logan's wealth and everything like right
maybe i just wondered to what degree he
[ __ ] them
like when he was like build your own
pile
did that mean like you're i'm leaving
you with nothing
i think it's sort of that because i
think for them
they
you know
they were kind of thinking oh we'll just
inherit one of the biggest media
companies ever right and we will
you know
we will get to
assume the same power that our father
had and we'll get to be that and now
they're just going to be a bunch of rich
kids with money yeah and they have to go
start their own thing and
maybe they aren't going to be good
enough to do that
god hell yeah i mean yeah yeah that's
the point oh my god i feel so bad oh
[ __ ]
oh jesus christ what what a horrible
life the only the only person out of all
of them who did it right was kendall
yeah he tried to kill his dad it didn't
work and just you know did drugs
[Laughter]
yeah that's what they should all done
yeah he was getting [ __ ] up the whole
time and the whole time he was doing it
right yep he can feel good about that
birthday now yeah exactly
oh my our dad was going to [ __ ] us over
anyway so yeah
i think he had it
so crazy
you know like we were talking about
yesterday the episode was shot really
well too
beautiful oh my god what perfect scenery
for an episode like that yeah
it's lake como right
that's where the uh matson's house was
like como like com like gummo talked
about this before but you uh but the
sides here are so [ __ ] funny to me
could you imagine logan only having tom
greg in his corner
he'd commit
oh
oh so on the on the succession poster
it's tom and greg on this oh my god
how did we not see it
how i love
i love when this happens and people are
like oh think back to the dialogue in
episode three yeah it was hinting at
this of course it [ __ ] was yeah they
write the end before they write the
middle yeah now i just feel like an
idiot
you